- So I'm gonna begin with an example.
So this is a very simple causal model.
It says that the amount
of wheat grown in a field
depends on the amount of rainfall
and the acres of wheat planted.
In this model, rainfall and
acreage are exogenous variables.
So for example, wheat
growth depends on rainfall,
but rainfall does not
depend on wheat growth.
And if you've done anything
in the social sciences,
you might know that typically
finding an exogenous variable
is a total nightmare.
You think something's
exogenous, but it's not.
But this is about as
uncontroversial an example
of an exogenous variable
you're ever gonna find.
But turns out that if we think of these,
not as just single events,
but as things that we're
measuring repeatedly,
so rainfall year after year,
wheat growth year after year,
and if we think about a
long enough timescale,
it could be that over a
hundred years, 200 years,
agriculture does influence climate.
At that timescale,
any influence of wheat growth on rainfall
is so slow and so small
that we can just ignore it.
Okay, that's just the starting example
and I'm using it as a way
to illustrate the notion
of the timescale relativity
of causal representations.
And that's something I'll
be talking a lot about.
Now, in addition to
illustrating that concept,
hopefully this will start to
illustrate the broader theme
of the talk, which is
that the relationship
between time and causation
and causal models
is a lot more intricate
than you might've thought.
So as I'll talk about
when we're talking about graphical
causal inference methods,
so people like Pearl,
Spirtes, Glymour, Scheines,
yeah, Jenann was mentioning them,
that these methods do not typically
in fair causal order from time ordering.
So that causes precede their effects plays
surprisingly little role in these methods.
But when we look at what's going on,
many of the assumptions
are really assumptions
about temporal stability
and stable behaviors
arising at particular
spatiotemporal scales.
And the point of today's talk is to show
how to use dynamic causal models
as developed by Iwasaki and Simon
in order to better
understand these timescale
and stability assumptions.
Okay, so let me start saying a bit more
about the relationship
between causation and time
in causal models.
What?
Yeah, so the reference is In
Search of Lost Time Ordering.
Shouldn't be competing with
Proust probably, bad idea, but.
Yeah, so graphical
causal inference methods
do not build time order
into their causal semantics.
So for instance, if we
have these two hypotheses
X causes, Y causes Z,
or X and Z are causes of Y
in standard constraint based methods,
we do not distinguish
between these hypotheses
by saying that if the first is
true, then Y comes before Z.
And if the second is
true Z comes before Y,
but rather in terms of the
probabilistic implications.
So if the first is true, then X and Z
are independent probabilistically
conditional on Y.
If the second is true,
X and Z are independent,
but dependent conditional on Y.
So that is the standard
implications of these models.
Of course people will sometimes say
that among observation equivalent models
that you can then use time,
but it plays often a very secondary role.
And in some ways I think that
this is a really good thing
for reasons going a
bit back to Tomas talk.
Because on the one hand
I think it's really philosophically useful
to distinguish between time
ordering and causal ordering.
For example, even if you think
that causes always perceive
their effects in time,
you might wanna know why is that the case?
And if you think that it's
just part of the definition
of causation that causes
come before their effects,
then you can't even ask that question.
So I think the fact
that using causal models
you can understand the
probabilistic implications
of the causal asymmetry
without referring to time
is a huge conceptual improvement.
But that being said,
it's still a bit puzzling
how small a role time
plays in these models.
And you might actually
just wonder well okay,
like how do we actually
understand the temporal relations
among these variables?
And I don't think it's
always totally clear.
So for example, when I
give talks to audiences
and I present directed to ASIC graphs,
so they do not allow cycles
and then someone will
ask oh, is that a problem
that you don't allow
cycles in these graphs?
And then if I feel just like
giving the standard answer,
I'll say no, no, no, it's
not a problem at all.
Because even in cases where
you have apparent cycles,
you can just time-indexing the variables.
So you think there's a cycle
between income and education
'cause people with more income
can get more education and vice versa.
But we just need to talk
about income at time
to equals zero causing education at time
to equals one and so on and so forth.
And to think to notice about this response
is it just presupposes that
when we're given a causal graph
and we haven't mentioned
the time relations
among the variables,
they really do have time relations.
We just haven't said what they are
and we can just time index them.
And I don't think that's the only option.
So again, the time-indexing
option, the idea is just
well, these variables just
implicitly are time-indexed.
They're what philosophers
or meta physicians
would call events.
We just forgot to mention
when they happened,
even though as Samantha pointed out,
that would be really,
really useful to know.
What I suggest instead is
that often what's going on
isn't that we're just
considering variables
that have times, we
haven't mentioned them,
but rather we're considering variables
that in some sense abstract away
from the temporal relations
among the measured variables.
So here's to give just some
sense of what I mean by that.
Imagine we have some vector variables
could for example be a time series.
Well, depending on what
assumptions we make,
we might be able to represent this vector
of measured variables as a single variable
for the data generating process.
So for example, if we have
a stationary time series,
then time order doesn't matter.
So we might not need to keep track
of which variables come
before others in the ordering.
I mean to think of a really simple case,
if all of them were
generated by some variable,
which was a mean plus a
time stationary error term,
then you could just have a single variable
for the data generating process.
Even though you can measure
it at different times.
'Cause time isn't making a difference.
In the event you have non-stationary,
it becomes more complicated.
And my point here isn't that
you can't do causal inference
with non-stationary time series
just to becomes more complicated.
And in general I'm just
restraining myself,
I'd love to talk a lot
more about time series
and if anyone does wanna talk about it
either in the Q and A after
the talk, very glad to.
But the point here is
just to give you a sense
about what I am suggesting
when I'm suggesting that we have a model
where we've just represented some variable
like pressure or temperature
or height or whatever,
it doesn't matter
and we haven't mentioned the time
and it's because in some sense
we've made some temporal assumption
that allows us to abstract away
from the temporal relations
among the measured variables
and stationary could
be one such assumption.
Now, more broadly,
I think that there's a historical reason
for why it is that time is
omitted from causal models
in this way.
And I think it has to
do with the development
of causal models as part of econometrics
and as part of the structural
equation tradition.
And at least historically
the earliest applications
of these tended to be
systems at equilibrium
or with relatively stable
time stationary dynamics.
And I think that history of the
development of causal models
as part of this tradition
still influences it.
Now if you accept this story,
I haven't really given
you much evidence for it,
but I'm gonna put it
on the table as a story
we might think about,
then the dynamic causal models
that I'm gonna talk about
are gonna be a generalization
of standard causal models.
'cause while standard causal
models consider a system
at equilibrium or steady state,
dynamic causal models generalized
to consider the behaviors
of the system away from equilibrium.
And the upshot of this philosophically
is that even though what
I'll be talking about
in the next few slides
is about the relationship
between equilibrium and dynamic models
and that might seem
really, really obscure.
Like okay, maybe some weird
causal modelers care about it,
but a serious philosophers
or meta position don't.
I'm suggesting that even
when people do not explicitly
talk about equilibrium and dynamics,
the types of assumptions I'm considering
are often embedded in the
models and not made explicit.
Okay, and the last part I'm just gonna,
yeah I'll skip 'cause
I'll come back to that.
Okay, and then last preliminary.
So I'm talking about timescale
and one way we can
understand is operationally.
So we're sampling some quantity repeatedly
and we can think about
considering the system
at a longer timescale as
sampling at a slower rate
to consider it at a shorter timescale
is to sample it more frequently.
And when I talk about considering
a systematic equilibrium,
I'm imagining that we're
considering it at timescale,
which all the variables
have reached steady state
by the time they're sampled.
And to be totally clear,
we could talk about
equilibrium and dynamics
without ever explicitly
talking about timescale,
but it's helpful in cases
where we wanna model a system
as having a steady long-term equilibrium
or tending towards a steady
long-term equilibrium
and then modeling transient dynamics
as perturbations from the equilibrium.
There's gonna be a relationship
between the equilibrium dynamic
and longer shorter timescale distinction.
Okay, so in the next part of the talk
I'm gonna now just give you the basics
of dynamic causal models
and I'm gonna go all the way
back to Herbert Simon 1953
Causal Ordering and Identifiability.
And if you get nothing
else from this talk,
we should all be reading
a lot more Herbert Simon.
That's just one of the takeaways.
It never hurt anyone.
Okay, so Simon's wondering,
at least in my retelling,
where does the causal asymmetry come from
given that many of the basic equations
of sciences have no built in asymmetry.
So paradigmatically here
we have the ideal gas law
relating the pressure,
volume, and temperature
of a gas at equilibrium.
This is just an equation.
That's just an ordinary equal sign.
So this doesn't tell us whether
pressure causes temperature
or temperature causes pressure.
So where does the causal
asymmetry come from?
Well Simon says even if we
don't get causal direction
from this equation alone,
if we add additional facts
about the system, we do.
So if for example, there we go,
we say that it's in a heat bath
maintaining a constant temperature
and for example that's
a fixed volume system,
well now we get the temperature
and volume are exogenous
and from the values of those variables
that are exogenously set,
we can determine the value of pressure.
And the basic idea behind causal ordering
is that the causal
ordering, what causes what
corresponds to the order in which we solve
for the values of
variables in the equations.
And just to be really clear here,
there's no magic here.
This is not telling us how
to get causal conclusions
without causal assumptions.
So to say that temperature is exogenous,
that's a causal assumption,
but it's just making a bit more explicit
where we get this directionality from.
And of course we could
have a different setup.
So it could be the case
that it's immovable piston,
it's now volume is not fixed,
but equilibrium pressure is,
and now we're gonna get a
different set of causal relations.
Importantly, when you can do this solving
for the causal ordering,
well then you can rewrite the equations
as ordinary structural equations.
So the type of stuff that
we all know and love,
you can give them a causal
interventionist interpretation,
you can add error terms,
then they automatically
satisfy causal mark of,
so from this basic framework
you can get all the stuff
that everyone's more familiar with,
but with an earlier starting point.
Okay, now why this matters for us
really has to do this later
paper with Yumi Iwasaki
where they claim that the
initial causal ordering method
was initially defined
only for static systems
consisting of equilibrium equations.
Now Simon had never really
explicitly said this,
but certainly you can see
that in the example I talked about
we're considering all of these
equations at equilibrium.
Also historically, Simon was dealing often
with the simultaneous equations
tradition from econometrics.
And you might wonder
well, how can you have
simultaneous equations
if causation's not simultaneous?
And the way I'd suggest
we think about them
is not that there has to
be simultaneous causation,
just that we're considering
the system at a timescale
at which the variables
have had sufficient time
to respond to any perturbations
and reach steady state.
Okay.
So now next few slides,
this is the technical part
of the talk and here I
really just wanna show you
how these models work and the
basic operations involved.
Okay, so we just saw an
equilibrium representation
or in fact two equilibrium representations
for the you know, two
different ideal gas systems.
Here I'm just throwing at
you a dynamic causal model.
I'm going to unpack this a bit.
So basically we're now considering a model
where we're not assuming that volume
has had time to reach equilibrium.
So we're starting by thinking
about movable piston system.
Here we have a mass on top of the piston,
which is, there's then a
force on top of the piston,
which is along with the force
in the bottom of the piston
influences the acceleration of volume.
Now these dotted lines,
these are integration links
and integration links reflect the fact
that if you know a higher
order derivative of a variable
then and you know its current value,
then you can derive its
value at the next time step
through integration.
So this is just you know,
integration in the sense
of the inverse of differentiation.
So these dotted lines,
the integration lengths,
they're going to bring
time into the causal model.
And one thing that's kind of subtle here
is that because you need to
specify initial conditions
in order to apply integration,
the initial values of variables
that are away from equilibrium
are going to be exogenous.
So the dynamic causal models will tell us
how a system evolves
from initial conditions,
but you're going to need to
specify the initial conditions
and this is gonna be different
than just an equilibrium causal model.
So yeah, and we include time derivatives
and integration links
only for the variables
that are considered to
be away from equilibrium.
Okay, so in any case, we have now volume
not at equilibrium,
volume and temperature cause pressure,
which influenced the
portion in the bottom.
And just to see how the
equation approach works,
it works in basically the same way
as the original causal ordering method,
except we have some more
exogenous variables.
'Cause first of all, we've added mass
and also the initial
conditions are exogenous.
And then we solve for the
equations in the same way.
So mass determines the force in the top
and the ideal gas law gives us pressure
from volume and temperature
and then the force in the bottom
is proportional to the pressure.
And then using Newton's second law,
well we combine the forces in
order to get the acceleration.
Okay, so that's the basic model.
Often when I show this to scientists,
at least to scientists
that are willing to listen,
this is way too much.
They don't like the cycles,
it's really kind of scary.
So just if it makes you happy,
you can also unfold this in time.
Basically treat all the variables
connected by ordinary causal
arrows is simultaneous.
And the integration link says
giving you cross time step
causal relationships and you
can unpack it in this way.
And one thing you notice is
that even though there's a
cycle in the dynamic graph,
it's not technically cyclic.
And yeah, so if this graph
helps you understand things better, great.
Notice that we're still
not using time ordering
to solve for causal ordering.
The really crucial information
contained in this graph
isn't that you know, we're
looking at what proceeds what
and using that to solve
for the time ordering.
What really matters is
that we have these clusters
of variables influencing one
another at different rates,
such that clusters of variables
that are very tightly connected
and influence one another
quickly at a timescale.
Those are influences simultaneous
and influences that take,
they're treated as taking
time over that timescale
are treated diachronically.
So this type of representation
is capturing timescale separation facts
as opposed to using the time order
to solve for the causal ordering.
Now most importantly for us today
is when you use the compact
not rolled out representation,
you can apply an operation
known as equilibration.
And equilibration is
when you take a variable
in a dynamic graph that
has not reached equilibrium
and you apply equilibration
to determine what the
equilibrium graph will be.
Okay, so this works as follows.
So first you set all
derivatives of volume to zero,
remove them from the model.
You also delete all
equations going into volume
and remove the derivatives.
This includes the integration equations
and then you remap using
the causal ordering.
And perhaps unsurprisingly,
when you do that
you end up with well, one of
our initial causal models,
namely the one
in which pressure and
temperature cause volume.
I'll say a bit more about that.
But again, the important thing here is
that equilibration takes a model
in which you had a feedback
loop and you derive the model
that would result from
equilibrating that feedback loop.
So allowing the system
to run to equilibrium
as a result of self-regulation.
Okay, much more familiar is
the notion of intervention.
So that's just the do operator
and sorry gave away the punchline.
And the only sort of surprise here is
that when you intervene on a variable
with derivatives in the model,
you also intervene on as
higher order derivatives.
So the thought is
something like you can't,
you know, intervene on
the position of an object
without also setting its velocity
and acceleration to zero.
Okay, so when we do that,
we get a different model
and in this particular case
we saw that with the
dynamic model I gave you,
if you intervene you get one model,
the one corresponding to
the fixed volume system.
If you equilibrate you
get a different model,
the one correspond to the movable piston.
And without going too
much into the details,
the fact you get these two models
has actually been a source
of lots of consternation.
So Denver Dash in his dissertation,
he thought that this was really a problem
with equilibrium models
for reasons that I'm not
gonna really go deeply into.
What I wanna argue is that
actually it's the right result
that we get these two
different equilibrium models.
And the reason is that basically
what equilibration is telling you is
what happens if you allow the
system to reach equilibrium
via a feedback loop
that you know allows it to self-regulate.
Now when you in contrast
intervene on volume,
you're not allowing that
feedback loop to operate.
And as some of you probably know,
feedback loops are necessary
to obtain certain types of stability.
So when you intervene on the system
and when you intervene
not just temporarily
but hold volume fixed,
you're not allowing the
feedback loop to operate,
you're destroying the
stability producing property
of the system
and you're bringing it to
a different stable state,
the one corresponding to
the fixed volume container.
So I think what's going on here
is that we just have these two systems
that with two relations
and the interesting result
is that intervening and equilibrating
just bring the system
into two different incompatible states.
Okay, so that was the
main technical parts.
Now we can sum up how
this relates to timescale.
So first of all, so we saw equilibration,
which once again it takes a feedback loop
that in one model reflects a variable
that has not reached equilibrium
and involves treating the reaction time
as if it were instantaneous.
Now there's another operation,
which I'm gonna describe
called exogenization, which
involves treating a variable
as changing extremely slowly
as if it were constant.
And using the timescale
picture we could think
about these operations
in terms of zooming out
and zooming in.
So equilibration is when
we zoom out to a timescale
at which something that
at the previous timescale
was taken time to occur but we zoom out
and we could treat it as instantaneous.
While exogenization is obviously
changing at a timescale
and we zoom into a timescale
at which the rate of change is so slow
that we could treat it as constant.
Now going back to our original example,
we can now understand it
in terms of exogenization.
So once again we had this case
where we had one model without a cycle
and where rainfall was exogenous,
another one with a cycle.
And it's a very simple example,
but the punchline is that exogenization
is the operation that
allows one to treat rainfall
as exogenous.
And the big takeaway of that for timescale
is that Iwasaki and Simon's
dynamic causal models
provide a framework for
capturing this timescale
of relativity of causal relationships.
So these operations allow us
to understand the relationships
between causal models
at different timescales
in a systematic way.
And one thing to note is
that the relationships
can really look very different
at the different timescales.
Okay, now the rest of the talk,
I'm gonna quickly do some implications
'cause really what I
wanna do in this talk,
I mean again I'm happy to talk
about the technical details
with anyone who wants to get into them,
but I really think that
this whole framework
and this whole way of thinking,
both in terms of timescale and stability,
it introduces lots of things
into the philosophical
and scientific study of causation
that at least as far as I could tell
other people aren't talking about.
And I really just wanna convince you all
that you should actually
think about it as well.
Okay, so here are some implications.
This one, first one is philosophical.
So as Cartwright told all of us,
"no causes in, no causes out."
I agree with Cartwright on this
and that means, for example,
you can't define something like exogeneity
without causal assumptions.
And I again totally agree with that,
but I think sometimes people use that
as a way to end the conversation
and say like okay,
well then there's just nothing we can say.
You just, you know, you say how do I know
this variable is exogenous?
And they say like look
at your scientific theory
or something and you go
well, thanks so much.
I have no idea.
And I think that we can say more about it,
and I think seeing how
assumptions that this exogeneity
vary with the timescale at
which we consider system
does tell us something
about how the world is
and needs to be in order for
us to make these assumptions.
So we can see for example, that you know,
in this simple crop example
that well we're saying it's exogenous
and we can allow that the
world's more complicated.
But if we genuinely think the influence
is minor and slow acting,
that would be a legitimizing assumption
for treating it as
exogenous at the timescale.
Additionally, I think
this does have some payoff
for some philosophical debates
including engaging with people like Janan.
So this, the previous
talk set this up nicely.
So one thing Janan writes about
in how causes depend on us is
building on the perian picture
she referred to, there's this idea
that causal relationships are relative
to the choice of exogenous
and endogenous variables.
And she has her own story
about how this choice does
depend on features of agency.
And I'm not gonna really risk
saying anything too ambitious
in this short talk, but
I'm just making the claim
that having a more, well,
having a general theory,
a theory of the type I'm providing
of what it is in the world that allows you
to think systematically about exogeneity
will also allow us to
continue that discussion.
And similarly for
discussions that have come up
in several of the talks
about is there causation
in closed deterministic systems
where you sort of reach a standoff
because again, going back to Janan's talk,
we understand in open systems,
what the exogenous factors are,
but let's just kind of generalize out
and think about the universe of the whole.
And we can define exogenous
risk of variation.
We don't know what they
refer to in the world.
And again, I just think
having more resources
to not just stipulate that
certain things are exogenous
but also think about
in cases we understand
what are the features of the world
that allow us to treat it like such.
Seems to me like a way to
advance this discussion.
Something else, this is
more on the modeling side.
So there's lots of debates about causation
in complex systems and here
I'm just gonna quickly illustrate
again, without giving the details
of how we can use these types of models
to really think about some
standard complex systems.
So one that gets talked about a lot,
especially in cognitive
science, is the watt governor.
So this is a device for
regulating the speed
of steam engines.
The idea was is that people
were using steam engines
to do work, say hooking them
up to a loom for weaving.
You want them to do regular work,
but the work sources are not constant.
There could be changes in the workload,
changes in the you know, coal.
So this was a device
that instead of having
to have some human there, as
you might think you would,
see the changes in workload
and respond to them,
this is a control feedback loop
where what happens is
you have these fly balls,
which have a mass that
are connected to a spindle
and if for example,
oh and then the spindle
is rotating proportional
to the speed of the steam engine engine.
If, for example, the steam
engine starts to speed up
above the desired value,
the fly balls start to go out
due to the centrifugal force
and then the spindles are hooked up
to the throttle valve in a way
that as the flyballs go up,
the valve is slightly shut.
So you get a negative feedback loop,
increases in speed above the desired value
cause the system to
automatically slow down,
let less steam into the
engine and vice versa.
So this is again widely discussed
in cognitive science especially.
It's also just a kind of paradigm example
and at least mathematical discussions
of dynamical systems and control systems.
In reality, people don't use
this design so much anymore,
but that's a, you know,
but it's a nice mathematical model.
So if you're ever in Munich
you can also see lots of them
at the Deutsches Museum.
So in Van Gelder's
seminal discussion of this
as a sort of model of dynamical cognition,
he makes the claim that when
we understand the behavior,
the Watts governor, the
system's entire operation
is smooth and continuous.
There's no possibility of
non arbitrarily dividing
of these changes over time
and the distinct manipulations
and no point in trying to do so.
So here he's giving an
argument against why,
what this system is doing
shouldn't be understood
using a computational model.
That's obviously not what what
we're talking about today.
But I think this type of argument
or this type of perception
of complex dynamical systems
as being such that every part
influences every other part
at the same rate irreducibly
also is the type of argument
you see people giving
against causal interpretations
of dynamical systems
and therefore it's somewhat significant
that when you actually try to
model the system dynamically
and causally you see that in fact
it is not such that
you can't decompose it.
And in fact you can give a causal model
of the sort I've been giving.
So basically, and without
getting into the details,
you have this causal
model showing how theta,
the angle of the arms
depends on gravity length
and the speed of the engine
and how the angle of the
arms determines the steam
led into the engine.
P is the workload and those
determine the change in speed.
So this is just an example of how to use
these types of models
to model a slightly more
complicated dynamical system
and hopefully give you some confidence
that we can generalize this
'cause these types of
feedback loops are not rare.
So this system is still relatively simple,
but the use of control
feedback loops is not,
and here we see that you are
able to model it causally.
And as with the previous part of the doc,
I'm not make gonna make
some huge sweeping claim
about you know what this
tells us about causation
and dynamical systems.
I'll just say that this
is the type of example
lots of philosophers are talking about
and people are making claims
about causation and complexity
and as far as I know, no
one has actually tried
to causally model it and
show this could be done.
So as with other parts of the talk,
I just think there's a
lot of opportunity here
to take a lot of what
philosophers are doing informally
and to think of it more rigorously.
And I'll just say that through the process
of building this model, I
learned a lot about the system
that I had not gotten from
the philosophical treatments.
So I do think it's illuminating.
Okay, now in the last implication
I'm gonna talk about stability.
'Cause once again a
feature of these models
is that looking at the feedback loops
and the dynamic model can allow us
to see the stability in sharing mechanisms
underlying some more stable behavior.
And I think stability
is one of those things
that really has not been
talked about enough,
at least not in this way in
the context of causation.
And I think this is gonna be a payoff
that also has lots of
practical implications.
So for one thing,
lots of inter interventions we care about,
they're not just trying
to change the value
of a single variable, but
really trying to get a system
to be in a new stable state.
So one example of this,
at least if I'm understanding it,
that would be chemotherapy.
So not knowing the underlying science,
but I take it what you're trying to do
is you start with a
case where the body is,
where the immune system is not such
that it is able to eradicate the cancer
and you want to apply chemotherapy
to weaken the cancer to the point
that then the immune system can take over.
So what you're trying to
do is change the dynamics
of the system so that once
you remove the therapy
it will be, it'll have
a different stable state
and one that is hopefully
more favorable to the patient.
I also put in therapy therapy here,
at least some types of talk
therapy are also trying
to change your patterns of behavior
so that you end up in a
different stable state
as opposed to the ones that
make you more miserable.
So I think to just
characterize what the goals are
of many interventions, we do
need to talk about stability
and that many policies shouldn't
be considered successful
unless they actually
produce stable solutions
and not just bring about an effect.
And I think discussion
where this would really help
is the discussion of causal extrapolation.
So this is the question
of how to infer causal
relations across populations.
You find out that a
certain education policy
worked in one place,
will it work in another?
Very often it doesn't.
And many people, including Nancy Carwright
and Jeremy Hardie have talked
about these types of inferences
and the type of treatment they, and again,
it's not just them,
everyone pretty much gives,
are fairly static representations.
So they talk about background factors.
Here they have in mind
Mackie's INUS conditions
where the idea is
well, you have these
different populations,
if it's a say a teaching context,
maybe one population has a
better supply of teachers,
the second population does not.
So that's why the cause didn't generalize
across the populations
'cause one of them had the
necessary background factors
while the second one did not.
And what I wanna suggest
is that even when we're
considering single population,
so before you get to extrapolation,
does this cause generalize?
We shouldn't just think about
some static set of factors.
If you're designing an educational policy
and you're hoping that the
kids will do the homework,
that would be helpful for the policy.
But it should be the
case that if you discover
that in a particular area kids
are not doing the homework,
that there should be some mechanism
that detects that this is happening
and implements a feedback loop
to shift the policy to
correct for that deficiency.
So to think about a policy succeeding,
we want not just to happen to succeed,
but also to be dynamically stable
in light of possible perturbations.
And I think if we started modeling that,
which I think requires dynamic models,
that would also help understanding
how we are not just lucky
when we get generalizability.
Okay, so just to
conclude, so first of all,
I've argued that many basic assumptions
of causal models are timescale relative.
I think timescale relativity
is hugely important
and presents both
philosophical opportunities
for understanding the
conditions of attribution
of causal models and for also
doing better causal inference
and policy evaluation.
And also that the notion
of dynamical stability
is different than the notions of stability
that exist in literature
because most of the existing discussions
are implicitly considering static models.
So thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
- Questions.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thanks for the great talk.
So when you do these model transformations
going from a lower level
causal model through,
I think you put it exogenization
and I forget the other one.
- A equilibration.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
Is there a change in
the kinds of questions
that you can ask, the
kind of inference queries
you can pose against the abstracted model,
and is there a change in the accuracy
of the inferences, right?
If you're making these assumptions about,
you know, this being a steady state,
it seems like there might
be some loss in accuracy
and so is there a precise way
in which you can know what that will be?
- Yeah, that's a great question
and the answer's
ultimately yes there can be
a loss in accuracy, but
I'll have to be precise
about what that is.
So I do think, and it's been
important for me to argue
that the models are
correct in the domains of,
or at the scales of
interest and to at least,
so in my Intervening in Letting Go paper,
I explain yeah, because you
actually do need to revise
some adequacy conditions
and causal models.
But I at least I've
argued that could be done.
But there is a loss,
and the loss is basically
that if you have a system
that intervening on certain
variables will destabilize it,
you're not always gonna
be able to see that
at the you know, larger timescale.
There's just, so the
dynamic model will kind of,
you'll see the feedback loop,
you'll know the result of intervening
while other models you know,
because you're just not zooming in enough,
you won't be able to see that.
So that that is a loss.
And yeah, and I think
it's an argument for,
you know, doing more
work and dynamic modeling
and exploring it.
But again, part of why I do wanna argue
is even if that's helpful to do,
we can still understand
models in the own terms.
'Cause at the end of the day,
I think we're always at a timescale.
So we're never gonna
get to the bottom level.
So we better have a story about why,
you know, why at least we
can understand models as,
you know, as being potentially legitimate
at different timescales.
Even if like any model they
might break down sometimes.
- Thanks so much.
So there is something that
a lot of what you said
just resonates with thinking
about practice in physics
where you wanna understand
stability under perturbations
for any system you're looking at
and you want to try to look
at different timescales
to see if there's you know,
things that you have to take into account
if you're really trying to
extrapolate over large scales.
And I was curious how you'd
characterize the contrast
between the way that
dynamical causal modeling
approaches those that distinguishes it
from just the sort of standard techniques
if you just had a partial
differential equation
and you're looking at stability
and perturbation analysis.
- Awesome, thanks so
much for your question.
And one thing just to say,
so I think the one person I've seen,
and maybe there's a bunch,
but the one I've come across
who I think really does
get the stability right
in the context of physics
is Yemima Ben-Menahem in her
Causality and Physics book
and she also has some interesting things
to say about stability and
historical explanation.
So I'll throw that out there.
In some ways they might
not be all that different
or at least here's one thing
that can happen when you,
when you find yourself modeling
something like the governor
and so something like equilibration,
it's not radically different
than what you do when you have a set
of differential equations
and you, you know,
solve by sending something to zero.
And in that sense, on the positive side
it creates a continuity
between differential equation
practice and causal modeling.
On the other hand, you might
be inclined to say like look,
everything you were doing
I could have just done
with the differential equations
and it's a discussion we,
you know, need to have,
whether that's in fact true.
I mean for me the
continuity is a good thing
and I guess I'd say at least this
'cause it's a longer discussion,
which is, so first of all,
I don't think that my
discussion says anything general
about whether dynamic systems
in general can be modeled.
What I've shown at best is that
when you have dynamical
systems that can be written
in a certain canonical form,
they can also be interpreted causally.
Now whether that's,
in some cases that might
not contribute that much
to the modeling practice,
but philosophically I
do think it's important
because you see so many
claims about you know,
again, not being able to have causation
and dynamical systems and here we see
that the analysis is similar.
Now in terms of what we learn,
I think it creates a bridge
where you can argue either way.
You can argue that
fundamentally the assumptions
in the differential equations model
they thought of were
non causal assumptions
are causal assumptions.
Or you can go in the
other way and say look,
you know, the causal is
just a unhelpful abstraction
from the differential equation.
So you probably know
which way I want to go,
but yeah, that's a longer discussion.
- So Chris, we have a Ben-Menahem
was part of a discussion,
so the video is available
on the website if you go.
So I have a very quick question
before the next speaker comes up to set up
and that is we can treat these
exogenous factors, right.
So in the rainfall wheat
example that you showed,
because they operate
on completely different timescales, right?
So the sort of a decoupling of timescales,
but underlying that,
isn't there an additional
assumption as well
that the variations on
that other timescale
that imposes on the
system are really small?
When we are studying on the timescales
that we have chosen to study,
the variations on, not only
is the timescale longer,
but the variations that it
can produce in the system
are very small over the interval of study
because we are choosing to focus
on a particular timescale, right?
- That sounds right.
- Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
So that's an additional
assumption that it doesn't have.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Great.
Thank you so much.
Let's move on to our next speaker.
(audience clapping)